Jennifer you talked about writing a
first book that did not sell and I find
that fascinating a lot of screenwriters
that watch our channel also kind of
think that their first screenplay will
sell you talked about how that was
actually probably a great stepping stone
for you although it didn't sell yeah I
can talk about it so when I first
started writing books my background was
that I had worked in the film business
for a long time so I knew a lot about
screenplays screenplay writing the
process for that I did not know much
about publishing I did not know much
about how to write a novel which is a
totally different kind of task so I kind
of said about you know teach instructing
myself I was largely self-taught I don't
have a writing degree and I learned how
to write and I ended up writing a book
and the book is adult contemporary it's
a first-person narrative which tends to
be a little more straightforward to
write it's one main character and a
little bit more of a version of myself
which is what most people write when
they write their first book and so then
once I'd finished it and gotten into
shape where I thought that it was worth
showing
I started querying agents which is the
process if you would like to pursue
traditional publishing that's the
process that you go through and unlike
in the film business we're blind
querying typically does not work in
publishing it really does work book
agents you can follow the submission
guidelines on their websites the best
thing to do is to look at agents that
have sold similar books to what you're
writing and to select them based on this
being something they would also be
interested in and then you send them a
query letter so a query letter has a
specific format which is usually less
than a page and will include a little
bit about yourself a little bit about
your book and it really is what we would
call an elevator pitch in the film
business which is snappy concise
hopefully hooking and eye catching about
what your books about and then if
they're interested you'll hear back and
they'll want to read the manuscript
hopefully so my first book which was
called all worked up and is about a
workaholic who gets sent to high-end
celebrity rehab in Malibu which is a
really fun story it's interesting I had
a lot of fans it landed me a dream agent
and agent I never thought would sign me
she insult the double Wears Prada which
was a good comp for my book at the time
was a huge selling title and so the book
did a lot of work for me it taught me
how to write it landed me representation
I was warned at the beginning that it
would be hard to sell because the genre
which was if you I mean this is one
thing that happens in publishing if
you're a woman who writes a book about a
woman it tends to get categorized as
women's fiction unfortunately in my
opinion and so the book that's a hard
John reduce L or was at the time so the
book went on submission but by that
point I'd already started writing what
was going to be my debut which is the
thirteenth continuum I don't think I
could have written what became my debut
if I had not written my first book which
was adult contemporary this is the
thirteenth continuum and it involves
multiple points of view so I was writing
multiple characters it's the first print
time I wrote in third-person which is a
little bit more of a challenge to have
voice in when you're first starting to
write and involves colonies in multiple
locations so it's a pretty sweeping
story they're underwater underground in
an outer space so my first book that I
wrote I think really enabled me to then
write this book I don't think I could
have written the story if I hadn't had
that first book under my belt because I
learned so much doing it let's talk
about how long a process that was that's
fascinating so you were working in the
film industry you decided to write this
book about sort of somebody going to
Celebrity Rehab or or visiting that and
then from that first time you sat down
to write it then how did how much time
went by when this was actually a
finished finished product in your hand
thirteen continued gosh I thought
probably five years from me starting to
say hey I want to write novels to
landing a publishing deal which is
actually pretty fast believe it or not
yes there are Cinderella stories of
authors who sold instantly at auction
but those are pretty rare usually
authors that sell books have been
writing usually they'll have a couple
even people like David Benioff who I
think is a phenomenal writer he's a
showrunner on Game of Thrones
he wrote the 25th hour I believe the
25th hour was maybe the third book he
had written but maybe the first he sold
something like that
and that is a very typical story okay so
you you'd gone to you got to Harvard for
film what were you reading or what were
you looking at that helped you write the
first book that you know eventually
transcended into your why a career what
were you reading that was helping you oh
gosh I always say right I always advise
writers that you shouldn't write a genre
or a category that you don't love right
so if you're someone who only reads
thrillers don't go ahead and try to
write like a romance novel you know like
why I'm not a huge romance reader it was
a hugely popular category at friends
that write it I should not be writing
romance novels because you know I'm
obviously geek for Outlander but for the
most part it's not something I read a
lot of so it's probably not what I
should be writing when I first came in
to novel writing there were two types of
books I loved to read the most and those
were what I'm gonna call female driven
narratives with female protagonists
which as I said is often categorized as
women's fiction and then big young adult
science fiction fantasy books so that's
most of what I was reading at the time
in terms of learning to write I always
advise people I just try to read really
good writing it's kind of like playing a
game of tennis you know if you play
someone worse than you you're gonna play
terribly if you play someone who's way
out of your league your game will be so
much better even if you lose and so I'm
always trying to find who are the best
writers out there right now even if
they're not anything like what I'm
writing so when I was first trying to
write really good third-person voice I
looked at Neil Gaiman a lot because I
just think he's an incredible writer and
storyteller and his books are so
engaging so things like American Gods I
looked at very closely the way he writes
character the way he writes prose and
then when did you find that you were
writing just like Neil Gaiman cuz I
heard that happened that if you focus
too much on someone that you really
enjoy then your Styles yeah it comes you
can I mean everyone says that when you
first start writing you know you're
imitating like imitation is usually what
happens I'm gosh I hope I'm writing like
Neil Gaiman you know because that would
just be amazing
you know I that's part of why I think
it's also good not to saturate too much
so
there are books that are really similar
to what you're working on I usually try
not to read too much of them at the same
time because it can seep in whereas if
you're just reading someone who's just a
really strong writer like Donna Tartt is
another one I don't write anything like
her but you know then I think just the
caliber of the writing will seep in and
you'll write better but yeah I think
most of us start by kind of imitating
the things that we love I mean the
strongest influences on the 13th
continuum it's part of why the cover has
such a classic kind of sci-fi throwback
feel is that it's very influenced by
Isaac Asimov's foundation series which
is a huge influence on me it's also very
influenced by Lord of the Rings which I
worked on the film's for and I'm a huge
fan of but it's not an influence in
terms of the way that it's written it's
an influence in terms of some of the
ideas it's tackling I looked at Lord of
the Rings for the structure of a trilogy
because I think the way that that story
is told is just really incredible and I
really wanted to avoid writing a series
where you know the first books great but
then the second book is disappointing or
even worse the third book is
disappointing because as a reader I get
really you know upset when I have
invested and it's not gonna deliver I
really wanted write a trilogy where each
book is really advancing story and
building into something big and I think
Lord of the Rings was what I looked at
to see how I'm he talking structuring
his story so
you